Nous sommes dit que la Scripture ne change pas, elle ne doit pas changer.
Elle ne doit pas changer de génération à génération, de contexte à contexte, de
une culture à l'autre.
La parole de Dieu ne change pas.
La Bible est là pour quelques versets, quelques versets favorables, plutôt que de régulier,
full-où, Christ-sérité, exposition.
La parole de Dieu fait l'œuvre de Dieu.
On n'a pas besoin de réinventer le christianisme pour l'adapter aux réalités du 21e siècle.
Parce que la manière dont les anciens dirigent l'Église, c'est par la parole et uniquement par la parole.
Dans cette parole de Dieu, on trouve tout ce qu'on a de besoin pour vivre notre vie chrétienne.
Elle est complète, elle est suffisante.
Le même texte qui dit que la Bible est divine, aussi dit que la Bible est suffisante.
Donc, à l'endroit où, pourquoi vous confiez la Bible ? Pourquoi vous croyez la Bible ? Pourquoi vous l'éritez ? Pourquoi vous l'étudiez ?
C'est parce que vous avez été donné un nouveau cœur et un nouveau cerveau.
Et nous devons prouver, et faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour obtenir la christianité.
est authentique.
Et nous ne pouvons jamais considérer comme authentique une expérience spirituelle qui ne respecte pas la parole de Dieu.
Le Saint-Esprit qui a inspiré la parole, c'est le Saint-Esprit qui vient nous apporter la présence de Dieu.
Et nous devons prouver, et nous devons prouver tout ce que nous pouvons pour obtenir la christianité.
La Bible est une expérience de la Bible.
La Bible est une expérience de Dieu.